today we'll talk about one aspect of
running your applications in kubernetes
auto scaling
as the popularity of kubernetes has
grown the community isn't the only thing
that's scaled up
you also need to think about how your
applications will scale
today we'll look at auto scaling your
applications in gke i'm caslin fields
and i'm a developer advocate here at
google cloud where i focus on google
kubernetes engine or gke as well as open
source kubernetes and today we're going
to take a closer look at the
auto-scaling capabilities of gke
[Music]
at some point you've probably been in a
situation where you've had to think
about bin packing
bin packing is the concept of packing
items inside a confined space in order
to use the space most efficiently
the same concept applies when you're
running applications on infrastructure
you want to use your infrastructure
resources you're paying for such as cpu
and memory as efficiently as possible
for example here's a diagram showing a
google cloud n1 standard 16 compute
instance with 16 vcpus and 64 gigs of
memory
the boxes coming from the bottom left of
the graph represent workloads you can
see that around 12.5 vcpu
of the 16 vcpu and 28.5 gigabytes out of
the 64 gigabytes
are utilized by these workloads
this means that there are about three
vcpu and over 30 gigabytes of ram on
this machine that are not being utilized
running machines that use these
resources more efficiently would help
you to optimize your cost
but figuring out which workloads will be
run on which machines and thus managing
the utilization of your resources can be
quite challenging
wouldn't it be easier if the platform
you're running your application on could
simply detect its required resource
utilization and adjust accordingly
this is the concept behind auto scaling
when using google kubernetes engine
there are four types or dimensions of
auto scaling that you should consider
horizontal pod auto scaling or hpa
vertical pod auto scaling or vpa
cluster auto scaler ca and node auto
provisioner or nap
this diagram illustrates these
scalability dimensions
on the top you'll see auto scalers that
relate to scaling your workloads or
kubernetes pods
on the bottom you'll see auto scalers
that relate to scaling your
infrastructure or nodes
the horizontal pod autoscaler and
cluster autoscaler which are both on the
left of the diagram
both deal with increasing or decreasing
the number of something
in the case of hpa that would mean
increasing the number of pods running
your workload to meet demand or
potentially decreasing the number of
pods running your workload when demand
is low
the cluster autoscaler can be configured
to increase the number of nodes in your
cluster to meet demand or conversely to
reduce the number of nodes in your
cluster so you're using your resources
most efficiently during times of low
demand
on the right side of the diagram are
auto scalers which change the size of
something
the vertical pod autoscaler or vpa on
the top can help you set the best
resource requests and limits for the
workloads you're running in kubernetes
pods
the node auto provisioner on the bottom
can select compute instance sizes in
order to most efficiently pack your
workloads based on resource utilization
together these four dimensions of auto
scaling provide tools that enable you to
run both the infrastructure of your
workloads
as well as the workloads themselves
on your google kubernetes engine
clusters efficiently with minimal
configuration as your cluster's needs
change
it's also important to mention that
google kubernetes engine recently
introduced a new type of auto scaler
called the multi-dimensional pod auto
scaler
as the name implies the new tool
combines the capabilities of the
horizontal and vertical pod auto scalers
in order to provide a more streamlined
and easier to use method to optimize the
efficiency of your workloads running on
gke
your usage of these four auto-scaling
dimensions will be a little different
depending on whether you're using google
kubernetes engine in standard or
autopilot mode we dive deeper into the
differences between these modes in gke
essentials cluster modes
be sure to check out that video for more
details
while these various types of auto
scalers can save you time and cost
configuring and understanding all the
auto scalers is still quite a bit to
remember
gke autopilot mode provides a more
hands-off approach by configuring the
infrastructure components of cluster
auto scaling for you
this means that when running autopilot
mode gke clusters you would want to
focus on configuring any of the pod auto
scaling options and you would not need
to worry about the cluster auto scaling
dimensions
these auto scaling tools can help make
your work easier and more efficient they
can also help you optimize your costs so
that you're using the resources you're
paying for most efficiently
here are some additional resources which
you can find in the description below
that can help you learn more about
optimizing your costs on google
kubernetes engine the four dimensions of
auto scaling in google kubernetes engine
play an important role when configuring
your workloads to run efficiently on
kubernetes
with the concepts discussed in this
video we're confident you'll be on your
way to building a gk cluster that suits
your needs
you can get started with gke by visiting
the google cloud console and checking
out the links below and stay tuned for
our next videos where we dive deeper
into gke topics